[Musique]
dans ce monde rempli de joie et de grâce
vous oublierez ce que vous étiez autre
fois c'est la frontière entre les monts
ouvrir des portails vers des mondes
nouveaux est une mission importante
c'est à tours et apparemment elle de
précis à présent ta place est ici si je
préfère ma ville avant la garçonnière te
manque ce qui manque c'est la vie que
vous m'avez volée j'ai pas demandé à
venir ici
mes doutes étaient infondées qu'est-ce
que faut ici
tu peut rompre la laisse
tu veux essayer
[Musique]
pouvons-nous éviter la catastrophe non
épargner des vies ballon elle
représentait
toutes vos guerres et épidémies sont
expérimentés chez vous pour qu'elle
n'arrive pas chez nous
si je comprends bien notre mandat et
qu'un violent qui a brouillon pour vous
[Musique]